hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and um
just checking in
on you
what's going on
now why yeah
you know what i'm doing right now i'm
sitting in the dark
i'm sitting in the dark i'm waiting to
do a show in toronto
i am at the uh whatever the [ __ ] they
call this place the scotia
nice to know she scotia center [ __ ]
bell pack [ __ ]
tweeter [ __ ]
target center
maple leafs building
um it's my second night here
and um
a friend of my my drum teacher
came in with uh some blue vista lights
early 70s
the the the event santa
was [ __ ] uh empty
and i came in and uh i got to tell you
something man
oh [ __ ] billy bottom foot is hanging
around
oh billy triplets
oh [ __ ] william twinkle toes uh the
muscle memory was still there i mean it
sounds like [ __ ] it sounds like
you know a stand-up comedian who's also
a dad who doesn't have time or any
musical ability is playing them
or the ability to say ability jimmy get
[ __ ] stuck on that word ability
uh which is weird
because the middle of that word is my
name you'd think i could say it
um
anyway so i sat down for like an hour
and i just smashed the [ __ ] out of them
they sounded great
uh thank you to josh davey lich's friend
up here who brought in his own kit not
only did he bring the kid in um
he had a friend of his on the bass drum
head the uh the the front bass drum
there
had him put a uh
a bb on there well instead of br like
buddy rich which was cool um
so i went up there and just [ __ ]
bashed for like an hour it was so much
goddamn fun
um because usually i just sort of do
you know one show and then leave but
this is um
you know incredible turnout here in
toronto so thank you to everybody and uh
you know what i like about the maple
leafs you know they leave their banners
up
so you get a really cool sense of where
you're at you know you play the one in
montreal they take away their [ __ ]
all their banners because they're so
[ __ ] stuck up right like oh unless
the the blue blanket rules
you know
you see me
they're not gonna [ __ ] put them up
there right
um
which i don't understand like i don't
know why they would do that it's like
part of the history of being in that
building is seeing all of those [ __ ]
banners and whatever reason they they
take them down
unless you buy a ticket for them
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing
um
sorry that made me [ __ ] my hacky
french canadian [ __ ] just made me
[ __ ] cough
um
but anyway this is like my third trip to
uh canada
this year and i'm gonna tell you
something right now uh
i would ever say i would say zambia
uh
i don't know
look canada
i quite like canada
jambian canada
i'm having a great time
right [ __ ] vancouver's great
calgary like calgary is literally
massachusetts
with with it's more like if texas was
massachusetts and it was in canada
it's you know something that's not even
true
my whole view of calgary is tainted
um
because uh meaning meaning it's skewed
not talking about uh you know
the porno taint i mean tainted as in
skewed um
because of the first time i was there
with verzi
paul verzi way back in the day
we went there and i don't know where we
played but these f it was the winter
time and i think everybody was going
nuts because they were like cooped up or
whatever these [ __ ] people drank
like i had never
seen and i really have to think like the
next two times i played calgary i was
anticipating
running into that because they were
[ __ ] animals that first time i went
out there
i mean i just remember all i'm like when
i when i think of it i just think of the
venue and just hearing the sound of a
beer bottle tipping over and then slowly
rolling to the front of the stage i
heard that like nine times every show i
mean they were [ __ ] lit
and then the last two times i was there
or whatever
it has been cool but i've just been
anticipating especially last time i
played like a [ __ ] park in the
afternoon
on the first show
yeah
it was great and then we also we were
downtown
uh that time and the downtown area was
great so i'm gradually shaking off
my first experience in calgary um
and none of it was
that people were [ __ ] they were just
[ __ ]
wasted
that's all i remember
so anyway and uh then i did a trip to
montreal which is always great montreal
um and then i went to uh now i'm in
toronto and i'm having a great [ __ ]
time i found a great place to get an
espresso i told you my road breakfast
my road breakfast i have a double
espresso and then an orange
after i go to the gym
and it starts the day off
right um
anyway so
so i'm up here with steph tolev
who's [ __ ] killing it
and she's from toronto
and she took me down to um first of all
i went to the hockey hall of fame it was
right around the corner it's the second
time i've been there
um and my big takeaway from that other
than that hockey and golf
have like some of the best trophies i
think hockey just overall
the trophies that they have are [ __ ]
incredible
um
i think i might like i like the heart
trophy because i just remember wayne
gretzky would win it every year
and
uh
then uh
and then also the the khan smythe i
always thought was a cool one
which i didn't realize i think this is a
trophy khan smite it has the old like
make belief gardens
you know which is pretty cool stadium on
top of it
um but my big takeaway is i want to uh
get some [ __ ] out of my living room sell
it or whatever and then i'm gonna buy
when my kids get a little bit older
we're gonna play that stand-up hockey
game [ __ ] these tablets and all of that
[ __ ] i'm gonna get that bar level one
that you play
and here's another thing too was the
kids were kids were in there and they
were playing like playstation ps4
playstation 4.
um last time i had a playstation it was
like 20 years ago it was playstation 2
and they were playing the nhl one it was
[ __ ] unbelievable i was sitting there
going like that's a video game that
looks like a movie
and i said to the kid playing it go can
you fight somebody
and he's like yeah he said all right so
he was playing the other team that
wasn't the maple leafs he lined up
against tavares
and i guess i don't know the computer
wasn't trying he just kept [ __ ]
uppercutting the guy and i was just like
dude you're gonna have to pay for that
later on in this game
you know he can't go after a goalscorer
on a face-off he hasn't [ __ ] done
anything or whatever whatever had a good
time watching them play but i want to
get one of those um
that stand-up game i want to get rid of
like it's funny it's the area of the
living room where i was going to have a
bar
back in the day when i was a big booze
hound i was going to buy a um
a uh
an art deco
like bar
um
i don't know i was into boost right
i was gonna have some humphrey bogart
level [ __ ] bar over in the corner and
then i'm like what am i doing
you got kids it's over it's not your
time anymore
all right
just be your age don't go out and get a
brazilian butt lift or whatever the [ __ ]
these people my age are doing now hgh
and
you know and taking before and after
pictures in their [ __ ] 50s what a
bunch of [ __ ] creeps dude my
generation really turned out to be a
bunch of [ __ ] creeps
you know have you ever seen anybody age
worse
than [ __ ] baby boomers and generation
x with all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
doing
jesus christ be a [ __ ] man
all right
there's nothing wrong with looking like
an old sea captain
these [ __ ] [ __ ] and you know
something let me tell you what they're
all a bunch of [ __ ] cheaters
all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] using all
these [ __ ] injections and all of that
[ __ ]
dialing back to whatever the [ __ ]
they're dialing back you still look old
as [ __ ]
walking around looking like an old
gorilla
um
anyway
so
steph took me down to this area where
it's this big uh it's just like a big
open market
and um
ended up getting a uh
what did they have
was it the godfather or a classic or
something like that it was sausage
eggplant plant and peppers and the
sandwich was so [ __ ] big i only eat
like half of it
um
but it's sort of a part of toronto that
i've never been to that's sort of the uh
the business area or whatever and um
i will tell you this man there's a fl
they got a [ __ ] junkie problem up
here
you know what i mean like every city you
know you got your [ __ ] drug addicts
or whatever
but like this is like the only city
i've been to in a minute where you know
you're walking down the street you're
like is that [ __ ] guy coming at me
am i nuts right now is that guy like you
know and then you're looking sort of
trying not to look at him but also like
can that person even see me
i saw this guy come down with this
[ __ ] look of euphoria he must have
just got a fix
and his eyes were up and he was [ __ ]
smiling wildly
and you know the deal you know the deal
with junkies right you're just like just
please for the love of god don't scratch
me
don't touch me
don't nothing of you of your atmosphere
get on me please
um
i swear to god he came and he was like
you know
this [ __ ] guy i don't know he was
like old school bald you know where he
didn't he didn't shave the sides
he kept the hair
so he just had this landing strip he
looked like a [ __ ] weatherman from
the 1970s just like tripping balls
coming down the street
little bit of red in his [ __ ]
stubble i mean this guy was he was a
[ __ ] mess
and i was
i i didn't know what to do like i was
kind of like
you know what i mean you just sort of
subtly
as you're walking and you're waiting for
you know any sort of quick movement to
spring out of the way
you know they got a lot of people
talking to themselves
um
but it's it's mostly normal people so
that's the thing that because there's
just some you know 99 of people are just
normal walking around very nice very
polite people so and then all of a
sudden like and the junkies are sort of
hiding
like amongst them like it's like they're
coming out of a corn field except the
corn is people you know what i mean all
of a sudden
you're thinking you're just taking a
stroll down the street you're like it's
canada man it's very nice
it's very quaint it's a nice time of
year to come up here
and then all of a sudden just like out
of nowhere like a video game junkie
[ __ ]
happy junkie happy junkie
angry junkie talking to himself
zigzagging diagonal walker diagonal
walker coming out of the crowd
fingernails you know just that [ __ ]
where you just like keep this the [ __ ]
away from me um
you gotta figure they get a brand new
batch every year with how cold it gets
in the winter there's no way these
[ __ ]
one-shoed [ __ ] junkies up here make
it although they have like those
underground tunnels up here
and i think they go on the ground which
is scarier because then you're kind of
like in these hallways
where you know i always felt like
you know if you're above ground
you know worst case scenario you can
kind of lead the junkie
into traffic
and you can let you know a hatchback do
your dirty work for you and that way you
don't have to like
touch them you know
what do you feel like craig what crazy
street person
like the way to go
it's definitely a front kick
you know what i mean if any part of you
is going to touch them you want to be
the bottom
of your shoe and i know this sounds like
[ __ ] heartless or whatever
but um
you know what what are you supposed to
do like nobody
for some reason there's no money to help
out these people which is really [ __ ]
stupid
the same way they don't help out
veterans the same they don't wait they
don't help out with anybody with any
sort of [ __ ] mental issues
um
yeah i don't know
i've been reading all this conspiracy
theory too about how you know
with water and food and how eventually
you know for whatever reason they're
shutting down farms
you know to just cause a scarcity and
food and it's just like what what in the
[ __ ] are these people doing
and why do all regular people put up
with it i actually had like a fantasy
of all of those sociopaths that sit
around and think about doing [ __ ] like
that
that like some group of people just
comes in and just whacks them all
i mean the entire family like they did
in russia and then they find the bones
[ __ ] 100 years later because you
can't leave anybody alive in the family
tree or else they come back for their
vengeance
like in all those old westerns and
karate movies
sorry i had a lot of alone time um
anyway but if you uh
if you hear a weirdness in my voice
right now
it's a relief
um
that the fenway show is not something i
now have to wonder how it's gonna go
that it is now behind me and uh i now
get to look back and reflect on it and
just think about how [ __ ]
absolutely incredible
it was i didn't even mention on the
monday morning podcast what a perfect
summer night it was
i mean it was absolutely
it was insane it was insane and it's
just one of those things as much as you
try to take it in
you can't
and then afterwards you just think like
[ __ ]
did i
get everything out of that that i could
have and and it was just i don't know it
was [ __ ] unbelievable
i still can't believe that that happened
and um
anyway so now like with that
off the slate
sort of i just feel like this lightness
and last night i had this amazing show
here in toronto
and i got another one tonight and then i
go to pennsylvania and then i go to
buffalo and then this weekend i finally
do this maryland gig that's been on the
books since
like the covid days
um
it's pretty awesome and then
i've said no to everything
anybody asked me to do anything i just
keep saying no i just keep saying no i
just keep saying no because i'm going to
be old [ __ ] billy football
hanging out with the kids maybe that's
what i'll do maybe that's my goal in the
fall is i'm going to hang out with the
kids i'm going to buy that [ __ ]
hockey game and get rid of those stupid
i was going to say book shows
it is stupid for a guy like me to get
bookshelves because i don't [ __ ] read
i try to read
you know whatever go [ __ ] yourself okay
i'm doing the best i can
so
um i want to get that hockey game
and uh it's just my son's a little bit
too little but
my daughter
would be fine on it
but i just feel like my son would be
watching us playing and then he would
want to i don't know
wow gives a [ __ ] i'm gonna get it
i'm gonna get it um
oh it's gonna be a good time and then
we'll have like
epic [ __ ] tournaments
and my kids will will uh learn about you
know winning and losing
you know
and uh
yeah it's gonna be fun because my
daughter does not like to lose like when
we play shoots and ladders she really
gets upset
you know
you know what's a [ __ ] on shoots
and ladders is that fourth row where
they have the back to back slides on
like i think it's numbers like
45 and 47 or 46 and 48 you just can't
get by those [ __ ] things
it takes you at least three tries
you know we just like whatever i do
don't spin a one or a three
three [ __ ] and then you go back down
again and then whenever i go up the big
ladder right
uh ladders and snakes as they call it
down in australia for some reason they
went shoots up here because we're like
too religious
all the aussies think it was because
we're too afraid of snakes which is
[ __ ] hilarious
afraid of snakes you want it you're
[ __ ] americans we're out of our minds
we've dropped two nuclear weapons on
human beings
i think we give a [ __ ] about reptiles
we turned our own food supply into
poison and fed it to our own people we
don't give a [ __ ] about snakes about
religion
that's where it is oh the [ __ ] snake
head told [ __ ] eve to go eat the
goddamn apple and whatever the [ __ ] that
is that's why not because we're [ __ ]
upset about snakes
um
anyway uh
anytime i go up that big [ __ ] ladder
i swear to god
i have like a 70 chance that my next
spin
i'm going down the [ __ ] slide it's
annoying so
uh anyway
uh let's do some reads here let's do
some reads here um
by the way the [ __ ] toronto blue jays
are only like eight games out i mean
they can't beat the yankees
but uh this is kind of fun thing to
watch consider my red sox
are just out of it at this point
i can just kind of sit back and watch uh
everybody else freaking out and die in a
thousand deaths you know
as you watch your team
limping towards the playoffs hitting and
missing towards the playoffs whatever
whatever your team is doing all right
let's do some reads here what have we
got we got one here one read
one read or another what song is i'm
gonna fight i'm gonna get you
who was that was that pat benatar
all right live read 8 25.
um oh look who it is everybody
the original
ride or die advertiser on the monday
morning podcast the one
the only
stamps.com
now if i had a hall of fame
for an advertiser on this podcast it's
stamps.com with all the dumb [ __ ] that
i've said over the years they've never
given me any [ __ ] they've never they
just they just been they've been there
all right stamps.com you know having to
drop what you're doing to make a run to
the post office is a major pain
especially when you got more thing
important things to do so stop mailing
and shipping the hard way stamps.com is
your 24 7 post office that you can
access from anywhere skip the headache
with stamps.com you've heard me talk
about stamps.com jesus christ they've
been sponsoring the show for over nine
years now and if you haven't
uh tried it what in god's name are you
waiting for stamps.com saves you time
money and stress all you need is your
regular computer and printer no special
supplies or equipment plus stamps.com
seamlessly works with shopify amazon
etsy ebay and more you're up and running
in minutes printing official postage
for any letter any package anywhere
uh you want to send don't mail and ship
the hard way sign up with stamps.com
today sign up with the promo code burr
b-u-r-r for a special offer that
includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page and enter the code burr um
so when i was up here
in toronto
um
up meaning north
i actually i went on netflix and i and i
started to watch taxi driver and it's
been taking me like two days to get
through the movie because i've now
become fascinated with every location
um
because it's actually the new york that
i first saw like the first time i went
to new york was in the early 70s if you
can believe it
my parents had my dad had some sort of
business or something and we went down
there
i mean the world trade center was
probably just finished
i want to say it was like 1973 maybe
i was like you know
four or five years old
and i came down here and it was all the
like the big cars the old school uh
you know
taxi cabs and i was just thinking you
know that's like you know
jimmy [ __ ] and mickey featherstone were
running wild in hell's kitchen and
um the five families
with dealing with these upstarts i mean
all of that was like starting to happen
and uh i think mickey spelaine
at that point i think
and
i think he got whacked i can't remember
but um john gotti was on his way up
george steinbrenner had just bought the
yankees and they were going to redo
yankee stadium and the new york yankees
were going to play in shea stadium for
two years
um
that's when they took that iconic
really sad photo of
i always thought of joe dimaggio
standing in yankee stadium and behind it
they were remodeling it
[Music]
and it was just really like the end of
an era uh
joe namath
at that point might have been on the
rams or on his way to the rams i can't
remember
uh but he's definitely you know it was a
couple of knee operations in
the big bad bruins were the big bad
bruins the flyers were coming it's so
[ __ ]
nuts to think about all that and brad
park had a rivalry with bobby york
that's the new york i was in it was
right around the time when zeppelin
played the song remains the same
i actually went to [ __ ] new york so i
ended up finding this
you know
incredible uh and probably martin
scorsese was probably just shooting main
streets right around right around that
time
and i was actually
[ __ ] there
if you can believe it
so um
that's not why if you guys could why
would you believe it for me it was nuts
i just wish i could remember some you
know it
so
i only had like few little snapshot
memories of it
so um
what was my point here oh my point was i
ended up you know through looking at the
locations of a
taxi driver
one of the things that he shows is this
was this classic
bar called the terminal bar
which was across the street from the
port authority
and it was known as the toughest bar in
new york city had a bunch of lunatic
irish guys in there like
fights all the time
and then
over time it gradually became a gay bar
particularly with
uh black men
and
this bartender worked there for 10 years
and he just took these amazing close-up
photos black and white photos of all the
regulars
and
the bar ended up closing in 1982
and
the bartenders like nephew or something
thought the photos were fascinating and
he interviewed the guy
and it's such an amazing 22-minute
documentary
um just look up document terminal bar
documentary i think that's i forget the
name of it um it's probably just called
the terminal bar i can't remember but i
watched this documentary what's really
amazing especially if you're an aspiring
filmmaker and you don't have a lot of
money if you see what they do with just
music
and movement of the camera in those
photos
in one interview what they make it means
it's a masterpiece 22 minutes
it's absolutely incredible and then also
it gives you
a
a glimpse
into where
new york was
like isn't nothing too i was in
new york when [ __ ] david berkowitz
was still walking around
how nuts is that
you start to think of some of that [ __ ]
you know
how crazy that was john levin lennon was
still alive it was a [ __ ] like that
part of new york you know and also if i
think of the music like probably cbgb's
was just taking off like all of that
crazy [ __ ] was going on and and i was
somehow in that city when all of that
[ __ ] was happening
i just think that that's amazing um and
it's sort of my favorite time
of new york of new york city to me is
the 1970s
even though you know the city was going
bankrupt and all of that type there was
something about it
um in the movies and [ __ ] that they made
back then that i loved but you should
check out this documentary uh just look
up the terminal bar documentary it's
only like 20
25 minutes long
um but
if you just want to catch a glimpse of
what new york was like back then or if
like i said if you're aspiring filmmaker
um
you should uh you should definitely
check it out so
with that um
that is uh that is the podcast um i'm
looking forward
to tonight's show and uh
reading pennsylvania
going to buffalo haven't been there in
forever that's such a great [ __ ] town
and then they're going to be happy
i'm going to go to buffalo and they're
going to be happy they're going to be
excited
because they got josh allen in the
buffalo bills coming back to finish what
the [ __ ] they didn't get done but you
know they they did great last year like
that's sort of um obviously i'm rooting
for the pats but i'll be honest with you
man i would love
that would be so [ __ ] great for
football for those fans and all of that
[ __ ] because it makes no [ __ ] sense
it makes no sense
that buffalo
has a professional sports franchise
that just doesn't
that's what i love about it
you know there was all of these places
that like you know like rochester and
all of these places in syracuse all had
professional teams and eventually all of
these [ __ ] greedy [ __ ] left all of
these great cities and they moved these
these these sports teams out of there
and they just went to the the the
so-called major cities
so even like uh let's see the buffalo
had um
they had a basketball team at one point
maybe it was the rochester royals i
can't remember did they not play in
buffalo i thought for some reason uh was
it bob mcadoo one of those [ __ ]
great centers from back then played
there but i just think it's so [ __ ]
cool that they've been able to survive
it's also talks it's it's a tip of the
cap to the nfl
with um
rev like but however they do it with the
parity
and the revenue sharing and all that
you know and i love buffalo bills
stadium
know i had all these [ __ ] new ones
with the sushi bars and some douche
behind glass cutting up steaks and stuff
it's [ __ ] ridiculous like i
love those old stadiums so um i am
actually
um you know no bills fan would believe
it because they [ __ ] hate the
patriots fans because they they forget
that jim kelly and those guys used to
kick our ass for like 10 [ __ ] years
and then you know
well granted we came back and beat you
for like 20 straight years
whatever but it's over
it's over now now it's your time so it's
gonna be fun to go to buffalo and see
them excited
about the new season and i love their
quarterback and their coach you know not
because he looks like me but i just
think they're doing a great thing out
there so i'm very happy for them
which will probably annoy the [ __ ] out
of them
uh but i am all right that's it uh that
is the podcast enjoy the music from the
great andrew themilis
and uh
you know and then we'll have a bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
once again i'll probably sign off
every podcast for the next six months
thank you again like this thank you
again to everybody that came out to
fenway park i still can't [ __ ]
believe that that happened that was
awesome all right i'll see you
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
august 25th
2014 how's it going how are you what's
up
um
right off the bat i got to apologize
to the members of the band chicago
because last week i actually credited
the doobie brothers
with that wonderful hit say
in the park
right
so my apologies i've always confused
those two bands there was always
something about chicago there were
amazing musicians but there was just
something [ __ ] i don't know what it
was
depressing about their sound to me
and then after those
uh with terry cath years then it was the
peter cetera
years and then it just kind of went all
like
you know
really high pitchy
trying to think the song i just remember
stay the night i liked that video on mtv
stay the night i watched his baby with
you
and then there was some oh wait ah how
the [ __ ] did that one go
something hot his skin getting used to
ah [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] remember
i don't know why you know i bought that
stupid easy listening rock [ __ ] so all
that crap is in my [ __ ] head now
i woke up this morning
and all i hear in my head is just
[ __ ] like yeah
something about this boat that sunk
they went out on the lake and they were
delivering oreos and then there was a
big [ __ ] wave
mark wahlberg went into the water george
clooney stayed in the [ __ ] boat
why does every [ __ ] song about the
sea have to be in three four times
is that one three four i don't know what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] that just makes
you feel like you're rocking you know
sometimes
the sea is nice and smooth
okay
billy joel and all you other [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there you have you never been
out on a boat in the water look like
glass
that's four fourth time
we got to sit there rocking back and
forth getting seasick in the crowd
because you're up there talking about
a goddamn seagull
as you finish off another jack and coke
i ate it
i heard
[Music]
even that's one of the reasons why jaws
was so amazing was um
you know you had the actor playing quint
this old salty dog right and even them
what are they saying they sang a
drinking song
show me the way to go home boom boom mom
tired and i wanna go to bed yeah regular
comment time
now shouldn't he been out there going
show me the way to go home i
[ __ ] shut up
with your [ __ ] peg leg she go get a
prosthetic
why don't you come ashore who is she
captain who are you running from
you can stay out of scene for the rest
of your life jerking off the mermaids
are you going to come ashore and try and
catch another bus
it's okay come here you can cry it out
you can put your one patch on my
shoulder
[Laughter]
um
i was just gonna ask a [ __ ] up
question you know if you lose a night
when you cry the tears still come out of
both eyes
is the the tear duct isn't exactly the
eyeball is it
hi do you know me i never took a science
class in my life or an anatomy class
they didn't have that [ __ ] when i was
well they had some of the science
classes and i [ __ ] steered clear of
them
okay
once you were passed junior high and you
didn't get to turn on a bunsen burner
you know that was the only fun thing i
remember taking one class the next thing
you know i'm [ __ ] doing like
open-heart surgery on a dead frog and so
it's like i don't want to do this
this frog had to die so i could hack it
up
this [ __ ] dog dog this frog
was having a great god damn time
right hopping around the christmas tree
right jumping around the [ __ ] swamp
eating flies you know that's what it
likes to do that's like fritos for a
[ __ ] amphibian
having a great [ __ ] time and then
some douche comes along i don't even
know how they killed the thing
you know they can't like
fracture its little frog skull because
i gotta uh you know
what do you call that when you cut open
something that's dead
uh grave robber necrophilia no that's
not it that's not it uh autopsy
like i'm on law and order
i don't know
probably shot it with like a poisonous
dart
you ever really look into the eyes of a
frog even look at the the [ __ ]
the way it holds its mouth
you know it's just like that [ __ ]
dude just he's trying to blend in
he's not hurting anybody
he's not the quarterback he's not the
burnout he's just filler in the class
photo can't you let him be so next you
know they [ __ ] whack him and then
here i am
trying to cut this thing open i [ __ ]
the whole thing up and i got a d-minus
on it
you know i should have honored that frog
and at least got an a
taking out its [ __ ] liver
um
anyways
uh what have i been doing i had a uh i
had a wonderful week i want to thank
everybody who came out to the oddball
tour 15 000 strong
i'm coming out to the uh
to jones beach whatever the [ __ ] they
call the that's the that
amazing arena
out there i'm not gonna call it by this
stupid best buy whatever [ __ ] name
they give it
uh but
i don't know man it was you know what's
funny is i haven't done one of those
shows in a long time in a long time
and uh i always go back to the virus
tour in my head
i always think i don't like doing shows
at night
outside
with tens of thousands of [ __ ] people
here because they act like you know
they act like animals
and um which really wasn't the case
on the virus tour
they just acted like animals on the last
two dates that i did and the second show
was imitating the first show so it was
really just the one show but what it was
on the virus tour was you knew that show
was coming you just didn't know when
it's like when you're creeping through a
[ __ ] house and there's an axe
murderer you don't know what room he's
in but you know he's in the house and at
some point somebody's gonna try to
[ __ ] swing an axe at your head that
was basically the virus tour
and um so i think whenever i go to do
those i kind of have like my my [ __ ]
comedy vietnam flashback
and um
i don't know and i went out there and i
was i was pleasantly surprised
uh the crowd was unbelievable
like 15 000 people and you could take
them wherever you wanted to go i
actually brought them down at one point
i brought them down
you know like a song
for the little breakdown the bob sega
part where he [ __ ] sings about how
many years went by all right 20 years
where they go
20 years i don't know
where they're going
yeah you do bob you they went up your
nose
you're out there having a [ __ ] orgy
yeah the decades kind of fly by
when you live in the rock style
lifestyle can you stop bringing us down
you're supposed to be up there acting
like you're having the time of your life
remembering everything don't [ __ ]
come down to my level in the crowd and
tell me that you're also wondering what
the [ __ ] you're doing with your life
you know what that says to me bob
there's no hope
anyways um
so i was on uh arguably one of the best
[ __ ] lineups i've ever been on at
least since i did the uh the virus tours
back in the day
you guys want to compare you want to
compare uh stand-up lineups let's start
a [ __ ] internet lineup i mean
argument here with the lineups of both
shows this is like arguing super bowl
teams who'd you rather have do would you
rather have the 85 beers
the [ __ ] 79 stealers
or any team with tom brady on it
and i just [ __ ] threw that out there
cause some people [ __ ] hate him
there's cleft chin
tom brady has an ass on his chin and he
[ __ ] a skitty chick from brazil
um
[Laughter]
i'm sorry you know what's great about
3-4 time i understand why you write it
because anything sounds important
i scratched my bowls and i brushed my
damn teeth
um all right so let's let's compare
lineups
all right so back in the day
all right that virus tour
the philly show as much as i can
remember of it which was a long time ago
um which by the way there's been more
goddamn horseshit
written about that show some [ __ ] guy
wrote this all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
about what happened that night uh when i
got booed
and i actually tweeted back to him the
correct story and then he just retweets
it
like like nothing means anything to
anybody no oh hey sorry i got it wrong
this dude tried to say
that bobby kelly got booed before me dom
got booed before me and then i was
standing backstage
with opie opium anthony and i said they
doing that to me
like i'm [ __ ] popeye
i have my little spinach here
um everything comes back to the sea
popeye the sailor man the [ __ ]
sailor
there's another dude [ __ ] a skinny
[ __ ]
right
what's with these heroes they don't like
hips
you know like some thighs there a little
thoroughbred prancing down the [ __ ]
road um
yeah that didn't happen
bobby had a great set that night
dominate booed for like 30 seconds and
he just he told him to shut up and he
goes why would you think i would ever
leave
and i was sitting backstage
going i don't want to [ __ ] do this
nervous as hell and then i went out
there
and i opened with a bad cell phone joke
and then they started booing me and then
what that's what happened and then jim
norton went out after me and never
addressed it and [ __ ] killed that is
what happened
that is what happened the first guy got
booed
seven o'clock
and then everybody else had good sets
and then i got booed
like three hours later
all right
that's what happened
that is what happened okay for the final
[ __ ] time that is what happened
i can't stand you no more
our matey
no it was realized backstage i don't
want to do this man i didn't need to be
here
i was like that dude and platoon i got a
bad feeling about this one man
um
so there you go um all right so the
lineup that night i will not name the
other person who got boot because i'm a
[ __ ] class act over here with my cute
little button nose
um it was let me see if i can remember
tracy morgan
bob saggett
ralphie may
bobby kelly damirera patrice o'neill
myself
jim norton
that's who i remember
was on that show what a [ __ ] lineup
that is huh
patrice the greatest comic of uh you
know my generation as far as i'm
concerned
i mean that's just that's [ __ ]
murderers row right there
and i came out like neil o'donnell
oh [ __ ]
all right and then last week last
weekend
i went on a show
and we had uh let's see here sarah
silverman
hannibal burris
louis ck
david tell
myself
jeff ross
chris hardwick
and uh who else was on that show
oh some younger comic and i [ __ ] up
what the [ __ ] his name
the young
the youngster there
and the youngster the rookie the young
fella there right
who do you like
who do you like but that was a [ __ ]
both shows you know what i mean come on
those are two of the sickest shows i've
ever been on so anyways i went out there
um and it was unreal and of course like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't get a picture
with anybody backstage
what an [ __ ] at one point i'm talking
to louie and dave
like two of my biggest stand-up heroes
and i got a [ __ ]
iphone on me and i never thought to be
like
hey let's get a picture i never thought
to do that now i don't know these next
weekend i'm doing more of them
to pay for the [ __ ] money pit
i don't want to get into that i'm not
going to get into that because there's
no comedy left in this [ __ ] project
oh jesus
i'm just when the job is done i'm going
to go downstairs
and i'm not going to have any money to
refurnish it and i'm just going to stand
down there
and in the echo i'm just going to start
weeping
[Music]
never
again never again i understand why
nobody did [ __ ] to this [ __ ] house
because to try to fix it is ridiculously
expensive and i am i am i am [ __ ]
done with it so anyways
i uh i went out there i had a great time
i was trying out new material and uh
it was such a cool i didn't even realize
how cool the venue was until somebody
took a picture from the upper deck
the upper deck a [ __ ] comedy show
how that that venue uh i'll actually uh
i'll tweet it out
um
on the monday morning podcast twitter uh
handle there whatever the [ __ ] you could
say at the mm podcast
join our twitter following we're only up
to we're already up to ten thousand
followers
you know
ten thousand more we can start at church
you guys will start calling me father
um right i'll grow a long white beard
and i'll start banging everybody you
[ __ ] you know
everybody who's there
that's what you do
when you can't when you can't play an
instrument when you can't tell jokes
and you still want to [ __ ] everything
that's moves your only other option is
other than hookers is you you have to
start a religion
that's basically what you do
and you tell people what they want to
hear and you bring them in
and you tell them that there's this
higher thing and it cares about them
it's going to help them and
but i'm the direct route to it you talk
to me and i'll talk to it and i know it
it it loves me and it whatever i say
it's going to listen to and i'm kind of
it you know what i mean i'm kind of it
but it's it but i'm kind of that thing
and next you know i'm it i'm the guy i'm
jesus i'm the father the son i'm the
[ __ ] alpha and the omega i'm the
[ __ ] uh foxtrot in the [ __ ] x-ray
right
next thing you know
you're blowing jesus
um all right
so
so we went ahead and we did the uh we do
the gig
and uh i
flew into new york friday for the gig
6 a.m flight and then i flew back
8 a.m saturday
i like
i landed at like 3 o'clock
jumped in a cab
traffic all the way in
to lower manhattan soho dropped my bags
jumped in the shower
got ready ran downstairs got in the van
went out did the gig
came back smoked a cigar with versi
stayed out until four in the morning
went right to the [ __ ] airport and
that was that was it i was right in and
then i gotta tell you i had two of the
greatest [ __ ] transcontinental
flights i ever had
i go to the airport right six a.m
and i'm sitting there like a [ __ ]
zombie right
and there's a guy sitting
like two seats over
he's sitting there like
you know those people they don't sit on
their ass they kind of sit on their
lower back and then the back of their
neck is at the top of the chair he was
sitting there and his shirt was up and
he was showing his mid-drift for
whatever [ __ ] reason so i want to
take a picture of this guy subtly you
know not show his head just so his awful
belly sitting there
his [ __ ] legs at a 45 degree angle
and i want to you know it's going to
text one of my uh
animal photos right and of course right
as i get the phone out he drops his
shirt down i'm like god damn it
you know
and i'm hating life i'm tired of [ __ ]
and all of a sudden the
lady at the uh the desk just goes mr
william bear could you please approach
the [ __ ] desk here please
so i got [ __ ]
what are they gonna say they gave my
[ __ ] seat away and now i'm sitting on
the toilet in the back and i walked up
and they they bumped me up to first
class first [ __ ] glash
so i get on the plane
and it's those first class seats that
are uh diagonal that fold all the way
down into a bed
so the second way airborne i fold this
thing down into the bed or unfold it i
should say
put on my little sleep mask
and just [ __ ] pass out
i wake up three and a half hours later
put the thing back up i ask if there's
any breakfast left they say yes there is
i got some yogurt granola and a [ __ ]
egg and spinach
quiche whatever the [ __ ] it is it was
delicious and then i watched mike
tyson's one-man show and the second it
ended we [ __ ] landed
it was perfect
[ __ ] by the way
mike tyson's one-man show
if you haven't seen it uh i highly
recommend it
um
it's uh
i don't know it's mike tyson telling his
story and what i loved about it
was
there was times you loved the guy times
you were like i don't know about this
guy
times you felt he was being sincere and
then other times you're like this guy's
you know as he says he was a hustler and
i'm just sitting there going is he doing
that right now to me
and in the end um
you know you don't know
it it was i don't know it was just a
really
first of all
what killed me was i think mitch green
or whatever the [ __ ] the name that back
remember that guy he punched in the eye
and closed his eye he tells the whole
[ __ ] story
and acts out the other guy wearing a
jerry curl wig
and
just sit down and watch it and tell me
you don't see charlie murphy on the
chappelle show
you know and dave chappelle doing the
rick charlie murphy talking about
fighting rick james i'm telling you this
his story could literally be the sequel
all i kept picturing was dave chappelle
reenacting this fight
this epic [ __ ] street fight that
started in a store
ends up out in the street
[ __ ]
with the other dude on top of tyson's
car
and tyson just giving up boxing and i
was just kicking the guy as they're both
on the ground i mean it was it was
unbelievable story and [ __ ] hilarious
and i was sitting there going why is
this guy
though there was a style with which that
he tells that story that was very
reminiscent of the way charlie murphy
tells the story then i'm like well these
guys are like within five years of each
other and they both grew up in brooklyn
around the same time and um
i don't know it's one of my favorite
things that i've seen in a while granted
i was laying in a bed in first class
eating a spinach and egg quiche
[Laughter]
you know you know judo freelander
said to me one time i watched some movie
and i was like you know i well you know
i was on the plane you know what i
watched i watched whatever movie it was
a movie that got bad reviews
and uh yeah i thought it was good i
thought it was a good movie and he just
starts laughing and i was like what he
goes bill every movie is a good movie
when you're on an airplane he's like
you're on an airplane you're [ __ ]
hating life you put this thing on and it
eats up an hour and a half of your life
i'm like all right fair enough fair
enough but i got to say this this uh the
tyson one man show which was done on hbo
uh shot by spike lee
um
you know what's funny about spike lee is
how he always trashes tarantino
about you know the characters dropping
the n words and that type of stuff if
you want to see something funny is how
how spike lee views italians
like
if italians could be in blackface like
in they should be in his movies it's
they always like oh what are you [ __ ]
doing over there
they're always wearing track suits
in my [ __ ]
it's ridiculous i just watched summer
sandwich i really like that movie but i
had to hit mute when that when they were
[ __ ] showing the italians when they
were sitting down at that dead end
street
it looked like a [ __ ] bad musical
from like 1953.
um
so you know i think he i think he's got
some work to do himself
[Music]
well let me get some [ __ ] spaghetti
get
um
all right
sorry that's my little criticism you
know you like you like you know there's
nothing better than somebody who's never
made a [ __ ] movie himself never
written one or anything now i'm gonna
sit there criticizing one of the top
directors out there right but anyways he
directed that and i really enjoyed it um
so check it out if you get a chance
hey you know what movie i wanted to see
and i didn't i didn't get a chance to
see anything
you know i was gonna [ __ ] uh go see
planet of the apes and root against the
apes as i was in the first one
i [ __ ] hated
hated uh james franco's character
in that first one
i i couldn't stay like
i went and i saw it with nia and was
sitting there and once he he gave that
[ __ ]
he gave that [ __ ] ape like pants and
sneakers and [ __ ] you know
it was just like dude what the what are
you doing
what the [ __ ] what are you doing
you're talking to him to an ape
don't give it pants
all right
you can't have the thing [ __ ]
dressing as good as you are
jesus christ
didn't you learn anything
from the british
how they built their empire oh that
little shit-ass [ __ ] little island
out there ran the [ __ ] world how did
they do it divide and conquer all right
yeah
you don't get to wear shoes
anybody at this level get shoes but no
pants
then the very best of all of you who get
to this level get shoes and pants that's
what they did
and then the people with no shoes hated
the people with shoes people with shoes
you know that's what you do
you don't go into your [ __ ]
hey uh chimpanzee yeah go ahead pick it
pick yourself out of suit
we're going down to the track like
[ __ ] eric roberts and mickey rourke
and uh
the [ __ ] uh i don't know the king of
print street whatever the [ __ ] name
that movie was
the [ __ ] was the name of that movie the
pope of greenwich village
ever you know sometimes i watch a movie
and and i go for the ride and there's
other times like people just do [ __ ]
that's just so [ __ ] dumb it's just
like i i i don't have any sympathy for
you should get your face ripped off
[ __ ] sitting there you know
you don't give a laptop to a monkey
what's wrong with you
okay
think of all the [ __ ] we've done to them
you know you teach them how to drive a
car
like how does that end well
um anyways yeah so i didn't see the
second one
i'll go to the one where we [ __ ]
defeat him
you know i'm a fair weather fan when it
comes to those eight movies
when the humans win i'll i'll i'll come
back and i'll watch that one you know
i'll come by for the playoffs
um anyway so after we do the uh
after we do the gig right out there at
jones beach
um
you know i'm trying to get back
to uh
to new york as quickly as i can
so i can [ __ ] go smoke this cigar
with versi before i jump on a plane in
like [ __ ] three hours so
um
hardwick had a car
so he goes hey man he goes i'm gonna
hang and watch your set we can ride back
to the city together i'm like perfect so
i go out do my set [ __ ] unbelievable
crowd
had a great great time it was like oddly
like intimate it felt like a small crowd
that crowd was so [ __ ] amazing and um
you know thank christ i didn't bomb i
had a great set i got out of there said
goodbye didn't take any pictures like an
[ __ ] so i jump in the car with
hardwick and they gave us a police
escort swear to god
out of the venue and up to the highway
but this is what's funny the show is
still going on
so there's completely no need for this
and we are basically driving through
a full parking lot with nobody in our
way with a police car with its lights
flashing
and we sat there laughing going are we
wasting taxpayer money right now
and we're like no well i mean they were
hired here anyway so they were already
hired for the event it's like what about
the gas and the cruiser
so there you go i got my first police
escort
you know and there was nobody there to
witness it other than me in hard work in
our driver i swear to god it happened
it happened it took me 22 years in this
business
and it finally happened
just imagine beetle mania if nobody gave
a [ __ ] that's basically what we were
experiencing
we had the nice car we had the police
escort and other than these screaming
fans
you know there was just sort of
yeah uh was a guardrail that's all i saw
looking out the window nobody saw him
anyways let's plow ahead here so then i
get back to the city
and uh
i meet up with verzi and another one of
my buddies
uh doug senier i'll be naming names all
over the place two buddies of mine from
the stand-up world
and uh we go to this cigar bar
and have the time of our life and both
of them were golfers and they heard what
the [ __ ] i said on my podcast or
whatever so we just start
we just start going back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth
arguing this golf point and i think i
can actually make my point a little
i guess clearer
and it's basically uh why i consider
golf an activity a difficult activity
absolutely mentally taxing activity
without a [ __ ] doubt
i i just feel like uh
you know when you don't have to be any
sort of cardio shape like you can be in
whatever shape you want to be and still
win
like a championship you could be a fat
[ __ ]
okay
and i was gonna say oh what about those
offensive linemen they're fat [ __ ] [ __ ]
you they can run a 440 or a five flat 40
those are [ __ ] athletes
okay and they are that size like the way
sumo wrestlers are because they have to
be that size
okay
they're told to get that [ __ ] big
all right
warren sapp
at his biggest weight could still
[ __ ] win dancing with the stars okay
you're talking an athlete here
he's still light on his toes there
all right i'm talking how you can just
be a complete non-athlete
you cannot even throw a [ __ ] baseball
and but you can be good at golf so
or pool or bowling
i lump all of those together
they are uh
they are activities with elements of
sport
it's like sport that you hit pause on
because there's no defender
you know what i mean and then you know
somebody just says you know
vos was saying you know that's
he goes dude the other day i was out
playing golf and i shot in the mid i was
shooting in the mid 80s
and he got excited about shooting in the
mid 80s and he goes next thing you know
i couldn't hit a shot he goes there's no
other game where that happens it's like
yeah it does
not only does that happen and every
other [ __ ] game goes well you
completely forget out of the play of the
game yes it does that happens in every
other sport and it happens in life it
happens in stand-up there's been
stand-up comics that have gone out
to do a late night talk show got so
[ __ ] in their head they forgot their
act
it's called choking in the moment
you know
i don't know i'd probably be a great
golfer because i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't respect the [ __ ] game
so i would never get in my head
oh my god i shot a 14 who gives a [ __ ]
i'm not even keeping score i think that
that's the dumb thing if you start
keeping score
i know the whole thing it's like
you're playing cribbage out there i just
don't understand the whole [ __ ] thing
i don't understand why people won't come
to my way of thinking of it why don't
you think my way so anyway we're arguing
this [ __ ] thing
and uh
just having a great time
and the night ends versi drives me down
back down to the hotel
we get out i get a bacon egg and cheese
at like four in the morning and then i
walk into a dunkin donuts and get a
chocolate glazed donuts by the way
people i'm off the rails here
um
with the diet thing
and i'm starting to go back up again so
i i decided this morning i'm like i just
have to step outside
because right now i got the crack in me
i got the sugar salt thing look at that
bacon egg and cheese salt through the
[ __ ] roof oh i want a donut i don't
want to donut nobody ever wants a
[ __ ] donut unless there's salts
through the [ __ ] roof and i shove
that down my [ __ ] pie hole like homer
simpson and then i go directly to bed
horrific
um
so that was the end of the night just
had a great time
and uh saw versi versus kind of uh
he bought this you know versus a sedan
guy right
because i was trying to convince him i
was saying one of the coolest cars out
there right now is the mercedes-benz e63
amg 4matics station wagon
they made a station wagon that goes zero
to 60 in like three and a half [ __ ]
seconds
to me
you know i got this like i like i love a
fast car but i love a car that doesn't
look fast that is fast a [ __ ] sleeper
right did i talk about this last week i
can't remember so i was trying to tell
him why that car is the [ __ ] and how
funny it is
if he owned that [ __ ] car
you know
if you're married with kids you know you
pull up next to some punk and they see
you there with your [ __ ] station
wagon and then you blow them off the
line you know groceries flying out the
back end i just think that's they know
and i'm i'm german right and that's the
great thing about germans
you know
is their [ __ ] their ability
with science is incredible you know
they're not the best at getting along
with people absolutely okay but
who the [ __ ] makes a station wagon that
goes zero to 60 in like 3.8 seconds huh
the [ __ ] germans
you gotta love it
you know you get that you get yourself
some strudel or a [ __ ] reuben there i
mean what else do you need
sorry so anyways um he's got this
four-door sedan man and i'm telling you
it's a [ __ ] badass car
but i kept he's got he's got to get some
rims on it
you know so i said to him i was gonna
bring it up
all right i'm gonna get i'm gonna this
is what i'm gonna try to use the power
what little power i have on this podcast
to get paul versi to get rid of his his
[ __ ]
i'm a 55 year old awful
i'm a 55 year old man awful rims on his
car so if you have a rim shot
a rim a rim shot a rim shot
it's a drumming thing if you have a if
you have if you own a store
and you sell rims okay can you hook my
boy version up if you hook him up okay
if you give him a sweetheart of a
[ __ ] deal
okay for some rims on his car you can
advertise for free for two weeks on the
monday morning podcast how about that
okay i'm throwing it out there
you gotta hook up
paul dude i called it
don't say him from jersey versy okay
hook him up because i like his cars but
his rims annoy me and they're going to
affect their [ __ ] friendship there i
said it
all right
um all right let's plow ahead here where
are we in the podcast 39 minutes oh
jesus i think it's time for uh i think
it's time for some more letters why do
you have a box of kleenex next to your
bed bill for when you jerk off no it's
for when i cry myself to sleep
um all right let's get to the um
let's get to the uh
the reads for the week once again if
you'd like to follow the podcast
everybody on twitter um our handle is at
the mm podcast
that is our twitter uh following we put
all the links up to the videos we put
all the links up for uh whatever the
hell i brought up this week oh that
picture of jones beach we're gonna have
that up there and if you'd like to
donate to the podcast while not you know
but get something for your money
just go to billboard.com click on the
podcast page and next time you want to
go to amazon.com we have an amazon
banner you just click on that thing
takes you right to the site i get credit
for driving traffic to their site you
don't have to pay any extra money
if you buy something
you know it comes my way they kick me a
little bit of something all right
[Music]
and with
that let's uh
let's get to the letters here
all right girl smokes a lot of weed
hey cincinnati bow tie billy
i don't know what that means i gotta
look that up um i've been with my
girlfriend for two years and lived with
her for about a year and a half she has
smoked weed since the day we met which
doesn't bother me because i used to
smoke myself what bothers me is how many
times she smokes it in a given day we
will sometimes be hanging out watching
tv and she will out of nowhere get up to
grab her bowl to take a hit i've even
caught her getting out of bed in the
middle of the night to take a hit i
don't want to be a dick and tell her she
can't smoke after all i used to smoke
myself
she just looks like a drug feed
always trying to get her fixed
i don't get why she has to be high 24 7.
i have a beer one beer after work maybe
one to two days a week and sometimes she
will throw that in my face if i comment
about her constant weed smoking which
isn't even close to the same thing i've
always said this about weed smokers
i've always said that about them like
the level that they get they get [ __ ]
high at work
not all of them i'm just saying you know
like they'll [ __ ] go out they'd be
like if i went on the parking lot and
shotgun the beer and came in like with
booze on my breath
um
and it is addictive
not to everybody but you can become
addicted it sounds like she is addicted
to this [ __ ] like she needs it to help
her sleep she needs it so she can
[ __ ] deal man
um
anyway she goes something he goes
sometimes she'll throw that in my face
if i comment about her constant weed
smoking which isn't even close to the
same thing she also complains that she
is broke it has no problem spending 100
on a bag of weed a bag of weed what
kills me is she will sometimes ask me to
help
i'll help her out with the bill or
whatever and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
how about you don't buy weed our
relationship is great this isn't a deal
breaker or anything it's just an
annoyance should i just deal with it or
should i try to get her to chill out
with weed what would you do with the
lovely nia smoked weed all day thanks go
[ __ ] yourself i would address it
i would definitely address it okay
um
yeah she has a problem with that [ __ ] if
you're waking up in the middle of the
night and taking another hit i mean
i always just equate it to drinking
because for some reason people can see
alcoholism
but they can't see addiction
with weed
um
if you were with somebody and in the
middle of the night they got up and
poured themselves a belt or two you know
a couple fingers of scotch and slammed
it and then went back to sleep
or right in the middle of a movie they
went over and just [ __ ] shotgunned a
beer
and i that cause that's basically what
they're doing it's not like they go out
and make a drink and they're sipping it
they're not that
you know they're getting high
they're not gradually getting drunk it's
like you do it boom you're high
um
and if she's doing it all the time
and she doesn't have she's not making
any money and then she asking you to
help her out
i mean if what if you didn't have a job
and you were drinking at the level that
she was smoking
and you were spending 100 bucks on beer
every week
and sometimes you know you would ask her
for help
um
what would she do
she would be upset now this is what i
would do i would bring it up
with her she's gonna get mad
and
this is the thing
you cannot get mad too
if she yells and calls you names and
everything just do not get mad just sit
there and know that she is
you know
you're going to lose the fight
if you bring up her weed smoking and
then she's like you know what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] blah blah blah blah and then
if you if you go to where the [ __ ] she
is there you're going to lose
because then it's become a name-calling
thing and you know she has successfully
gotten it out of the arena of what she's
doing is [ __ ] up
uh you i you just need to stay in the
pocket and be like listen
i don't mind that you smoke weed i drink
beer
okay
but you are smoking weed 24 7. you're
getting up in the middle of the night
and you're smoking weed and i'm worried
about you and you're asking me on
something you're blowing dollars a week
on weed and you're asking me to help you
out sometime
okay now in all fairness
if i was blowing a hundred bucks on beer
every week and i was you know waking up
in the middle of the night
drinking a beer
and they're gonna pull that [ __ ] that
isn't the same thing yes it is it is the
same thing you're altering your mental
state
with alcohol but except you're using
you're you're using marijuana
all right and uh you know i care about
you
and you're kind of going down you know
it's basically it's your job
to keep your woman in line and it's her
job to keep you in line
and that isn't some sexist [ __ ] but when
i say keep you in line which just means
when they see you going out of bounds
they see you going up river a little bit
like colonel kurtz shaving your head go
on the horror as you sit there in the
corner [ __ ] shotgun and a beer it's
her job to be like i think you're
starting to your drinking's getting a
little out of control
that's what you do when you love
somebody so
just know that she might not be ready to
hear that [ __ ] but you know she has to
hear it from you
you're just trying to help her out if
she flips out calls you a bunch of names
just say listen let's
i've said what i had to say i'm more
than willing to discuss this with you
later when you've calmed down but i'm
not going to get into a name-calling
uh
argument with you and you leave it at
that and then
they have no [ __ ] choice
they have no choice
other than to just [ __ ] chill at that
point or they continue calling your
names but if
after that they're gonna they're gonna
owe you an apology
all right and if they don't apologize
and they can't admit that they're wrong
that's a whole other [ __ ] red flag
you know
because i couldn't be in a [ __ ]
relationship once if with somebody who
you know if they [ __ ] up can't be like
all right you know what you were right
on that one you know you got to have
that if you don't have that i don't know
what the [ __ ] you got so good luck with
that sir all right
next one what the [ __ ] to do
cerber
love the show and listen weekly thanks
for making my money's entertaining well
you're welcome all right i am 39 and
separated with the child and i started
seeing a woman who was 43 divorced with
their own child but up and up here's a
story
about two months into the relationship
we were getting serious and we started
discussing a future together however our
relationship started to erode about as
quickly as it started and we ended up
breaking up after dating a total of six
months
one of the reasons we ended things was
that we didn't agree on wanting more
kids she wanted more but i didn't we
ended on such a bad note that we agreed
to not talk anymore
um okay at this point i'm like good
that was a very mature
relationship
early on you said what you both wanted
you realized that you didn't you wanted
two different things and you walked
got a little ugly there for a second but
who gives a [ __ ]
anyways
he goes as luck would have it about two
to three weeks after we broke up she
called me
to tell me she is pregnant
oh my god
wait a minute
she wanted more and i didn't she pulled
the goalie
oh dude you didn't want more kids you
didn't use a condom
oh my god she go he goes i did not know
how it was possible okay because we took
precautions but i guess i slipped up i
slipped one past the goalie i was
devastated and worried because not only
do i not want more kids my current
financial situation would limit me
greatly in my ability to take care of my
child and another child
my question to you is what the [ __ ] do i
do
i would get a paternity test
definitely get a paternity test to make
sure it's yours
um if you don't want to i mean that's
and that's a prayer
i'm not saying anything bad about this
woman but just you know you got to throw
the hail mary here and hope maybe you
get lucky because my question to you is
what the [ __ ] do i do she doesn't want
to have
an abortion
and told me that we should get back
together and have the baby
is she lying
she said if not she would try to legally
prevent me from
having a part
being part of the child's life
as i was writing this she was about six
weeks pregnant so a lot of time
a lot of time to stress about it
um yeah dude [ __ ] all of that
she's gonna i mean
wait a minute let me just read the last
paragraph of this because i'm not stupid
enough
to go to a comedian for advice however i
do think you have an interesting
perspective on life and i'd love to hear
your point of view this situation has
since been resolved
see below to see how it turned out but
the but answer the question before you
see the result thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself well i don't see the results
here
below i'd love to know what happened
jesus now you're leaving me hanging and
now my listeners
all right here's my thing if any woman
said you know you got me pregnant
and i didn't want to be with her
and she said uh if you don't
live with me and we have a relationship
you'll never see
uh the kid i i would just be like that's
no way to go into a relationship
okay you want to find love
okay and the way to find true love is
not to hold somebody hostage
okay
we made a mistake
now we're going to be adults and we are
going to raise this child in an
unconventional way
because we do not love each other so
it's not going to be fair to the kid if
we're both together it also will not be
fair to the kid if you prevent the kid
from seeing the mother his mother or his
father
okay so we need to be adults and put
this kid first and set aside our
differences and be
as mature about this as we possibly can
the next 18 years are critical in this
kid's life and we need to suck it up all
right
so let's get on the same damn page here
all right
i mean somewhere along the lines i would
i would say that but i would definitely
get a [ __ ] paternity test
um because you never know what
somebody's doing
and uh you know you kind of seem like
dumbfounded that you actually got a
pregnant who knows what happens she
seems like she wants more kids she could
be this desperate person that was you
know
i don't know what but uh stranger things
have happened so i would definitely get
a paternity test and if she gets mad
[ __ ] her who gives a [ __ ]
if she gets mad and be like listen
you know you shouldn't say this but in
your head you got to be thinking this is
somebody who's [ __ ] crazy enough to
basically threaten me into her life
if you're crazy enough to do that you're
crazy enough to say a kid that isn't
mine is mine
okay she's not acting stable right now
so
i don't know
and that is healthy paranoia
that is not uh you know
you know if i ever said some [ __ ] like
that on the view
you know what kills me is they would
they would tow the company line but i
swear to god backstage
you know [ __ ] is crazy
um phil collins in genesis
uh oh by the way we're talking drummers
here i didn't realize this i um
i just got tickets to go see primus
uh band that i've always been meaning to
see and uh tim herb alexander is back in
the band
and i love the way that that guy i
always loved the way that guys played
and um i got some tickets
me and roses joey roses are going joey
roses by the way who has a new comedy cd
coming out
i believe september 2nd
he's going to give me all the details
but uh
go to joe
derosacomedy.com i believe is his
website i don't know what his [ __ ]
website is why don't i do a better job
promoting an old pals [ __ ] website by
actually having the decency of looking
it up here sorry for the poor audio
quality right now
all right
joe derosa has a website i don't know
what it's [ __ ] called
you call yourself yeah joe
derosacomedy.com
all right let's see what he's got here
he has some shoulders but he lacks the
meat between his neck and ball sockets
all right where do we go here
why is my [ __ ] internet so god damn
slow whatever it's joe derosacomedy.com
he's got a new [ __ ] comedy cd coming
out and uh goddamn and i stand behind it
as does everybody else here in this
podcast which should basically be me but
anyways so uh i i i didn't realize that
uh tim alexander had a heart attack
um but he's doing great he's recovering
well uh judging by the stuff that i've
seen him post
on his twitter account and that type of
thing uh i'm really happy for him
because he's truly is one of the great
drummers of the last uh
24 years jesus christ hasn't been that
long since uh i've been listening to him
but um
so whatever it just somehow gets to him
happy to hear that you're doing well
and uh continued healthy lifestyle
all righty okay um phil collins in
genesis
may have been done
oh by the way thank you to everybody
that also donated to uh
benny greb's
um dvd he's up he needs like he's raised
99 of the money so that really means a
lot to me
and uh it's going to help other drummers
which will help music which will come
back around even if you don't play drums
you get to listen to better drummers
making better music so i really
appreciate everybody
who uh donated that was pretty awesome
all right okay last time starting this
bill phil collins of genesis
may have been done before but hey billy
bruford you're a drummer stupid you must
know him i am you'd have to insult me
because you felt insecure about your
obscure reference
um all right on last week's podcast you
brought up mr phil collins in genesis
you absolutely nailed how incredible
phil is as a drummer i am an early
genesis fanatic from trespass nursery
crime foxtrot
selling in england by the pound
and the lamb lies down on broadway
and he has in parentheses dude you know
what's funny is i don't know anything
about early genesis i just know phil
collins is a [ __ ] amazing drummer i
know that they were a prague rock band
and that peter gabriel who later sung
sledgehammer gave himself a reverse
mohawk at some point when he was in that
band
anyways he says that dude
as you may guess
should be boss well bostonian because
it's
the best album well the lamb lies down
on broadway do
that's what that's how that was supposed
to be read all right well i'll check
that one out
anyways he said when peter gabriel left
the band in 1975
these guys auditioned singers for months
no one could get it right so what did
old phil collins do he stepped
out from behind the drum kit like a
badass and took over the role as front
man and drummer from there they remained
true to their roots for a while i'd say
at least three to four albums and until
of course as you pointed out the cash
cow came along and they climbed aboard
the proverbial money train uh but that
should
but that should not discredit these guys
they have my ultimate respect yeah it
gives a [ __ ] and in the end you finally
wanted to get paid and go out and get
yourself a [ __ ]
station wagon that went 0-60 in 3.5
seconds i totally get that
you know
phil collins kept it real he never got
hair plugs or a toupee
he just held onto that landing strip
forever
however that's not to mention uh however
that's not to mention brand x which was
phil's jazz fusion side project that's
where his drumming really flourished the
album product is a must
dude this is like some hardcore
music geek [ __ ] and i'm loving every
second of this
um phil always surrounded himself with
brilliant drummers hey there cleo bill
brewford there
and uh chester thompson of zappa fame
not to mention that bitchin tarzan theme
right no
tarzan theme tarzan
um sorry i've been out here too long
sticking tarzana
on thursday august 21st genesis posted
to their official facebook page a new
logo and a promise for exciting news
some have speculated a possible reunion
with the 71-75 lineup including peter
gabriel and steve hackett which i would
come buckets for jesus christ dude
i don't need that visual he said i am a
musician bill and i love when you bring
up your drumming you bring your drumming
up and music in general keep it up
and the mike in the mechanic's name
mike in the mechanics dude's name is
mike rutherford how british can you get
cozy smug [ __ ]
um
i am uh
yeah i love all that type of [ __ ] do you
know
i'm gonna do another one of those
goddamn comedy jams i can't figure out
what song i'm gonna do
um but some of the songs i've been
messing with
have double bass in them and uh that's
something that
uh
when it comes to double bass drumming i
am i am a a snob
when it comes to it i'm actually a [ __ ]
when it comes to double bass drumming
because i can't do it on any level but i
have some hardcore opinions about it
um
i don't like when somebody uses it
to enhance all their [ __ ] fills
around the kit
just running underneath or just doing
the quad thing or whatever like i
that always annoyed me because it makes
you sound
you're doing these bottom quads but i
know you're kind of cheating
but um however if you get somebody
who actually utilizes it
to enhance
a groove or even a fill like i would say
uh tim alexander like some of the
drumming that that guy's
recorded is is just
it's astounding like i feel like
like i kind of got into this thing where
i felt guys who played single bass drum
could play a better groove
than somebody that played double bass
because they uh
i'm trying to i how do i equate you just
had this extra it's like you had this
howitzer underneath you and they just
couldn't
resist
jumping on those [ __ ] things every
chance they had
to do some insane sounding fill
and i always felt like the guys
i just felt like the guys that had the
least amount of [ __ ] played the best
like is steve jordan you know played a
little four piece kid i mean that guy
could literally could just give him a
high head a ride symbol
bass drum and snare like a quest love
same thing and that guy could get more
goddamn music out of it than some guy
that has like a 50 piece set like i kind
of went into that and then
which was there was an element of truth
to it but it was it was an arrogant
like mindset it would be the same thing
as it would be like a clean comic is
better than a dirty comic and you're not
listening to what they're saying
so uh i've actually come around now and
there's a bunch of players that uh
that i like but it's but like if there's
no groove i can't get into it if you're
just [ __ ] playing like a zillion
miles an hour like i gotta admit like
those uh
those blast beats and that type of thing
that's [ __ ] insane that somebody can
do that but after a while
it's it's just played so [ __ ] fast i
it all sounds the same maybe i need to
listen to more of it to be able to uh
hear it but my favorite part in death
metal is when the singer for like half a
second you actually hear what his
singing voice really sounds like before
he goes back to
that type of [ __ ]
so um
anyways um
so i've been i'm [ __ ] around with
some uh
some of that double bass [ __ ] i'm not
i'm not gonna say what it is because uh
you know the reveal like i guess i
wasn't supposed to say that i was gonna
dress up like tommy lee
last week um did i talk about that by
the way we [ __ ]
we smashed it man we got off to a
a little rough start i [ __ ] i always
[ __ ] up the beginning
um
but i was psyched because i [ __ ] it up
in that i didn't stop when i was
supposed to then restart but i just kind
of kept going and if you didn't know the
song you wouldn't notice that we [ __ ]
up so i felt good about that and uh
and you know once again it took us a
second then we got on track it's just
kind of hard to come walking out
and be doing stand-up
and then finish that and then walk
behind the kitten and count off a ban
and not [ __ ] it up it might at my
drumming level it's a very difficult
thing to do
uh
hang on a second i've been given a note
here need to get my stuff
um
okay
all right i'll see you
um anyways
so let's go let's let's plow ahead here
all right girl stalker
hi mr belt i am from the czech republic
well how are you how's it going do you
ever go up to hungary and get some of
that [ __ ] uh art deco furniture that
they send over here
what is it from budapest
you don't charge us a [ __ ] zillion
dollars for it anyways he goes i listen
to the monday morning podcast like every
single week and i love what you're doing
well thank you he goes i know you don't
owe me anything but i really need some
advice right now yes i do owe you
because you're walking around the czech
republic going have you [ __ ] heard
about this red-headed [ __ ] over there in
the states and someday i'll do a gig in
prague
you guys got a funny bone over there
cause i'll do it
um he said there's a chick living in my
neighborhood and she's really into me
i mean a lot and and much more
i would like to also say your english
was [ __ ] unreal and i wasn't
believing that you were from the czech
republic by going this is there was a
chick living in my neighborhood
you're using the slang properly
and then the next sentence he goes i
mean a lot and much more i would like to
alright
she calls me in the middle of the night
keeps knocking on my door calling my
name throws rocks at my window and once
climbed on a tree next to my house came
inside my room and wait waited under my
bed until i arrived
yeah dude you can't have this
that's [ __ ] creepy
i didn't even know
she wasn't barefoot was she she's
barefoot i think she's a vampire
you know they always barefoot and they
have like their breath is cold
i don't know how jesus he goes i didn't
even know there was something
like girl stalking but now i'm starting
to be worried the only thing
i did was helping her back on her feet
when she fade out on my friend's party
couple of months ago i don't want to be
mean or hurt her feelings she's pretty
nice girl but this is way over the line
any advice yeah you gotta tell her to
screw
um
you have to totally cut her off and you
can't have any interaction with her
because any sort of interaction with
this woman is gonna make her feel like
you guys that justifies her relationship
you know what i mean
um
i feel bad that she's in this mind state
but you don't have to deal with it uh
first of all lock your [ __ ] window
and um if she ever comes in your house
again
you need to call the cops
i would stand outside and have the cops
go in and get her out and i would have
legal record that that's what she did
okay and then don't talk to her at all
don't answer the phone
don't
nothing
nothing
and you have to you have to cut her out
of your life because she's out of her
[ __ ] mind
all right
that's what i would do and when she
cries or does whatever do not comfort
her and go i'm sorry but i'm just not
into you because in her world the
relationship just started over again you
have to [ __ ] you have to
you got to cut the head off the snake
end it
all right there you go all right when is
too old to start a band
well listen i just started playing out
with
i'm not in a band but i gotta tell you
dude it's
[ __ ] i got to tell you something
going down and doing that goddamn comedy
jam and sitting in with the band is the
most fun [ __ ] i've done in a long time i
literally drive down there with like
butterflies
like this nervous excitement you know
how long it's been since i've had that
i'm getting outside my comfort zone and
uh
i know obviously i'm not gonna join a
band or anything but whatever that
experience is artistically is gonna help
me in my acting it's somewhere down the
road that experience is gonna [ __ ]
help me and um
i don't know it's just that's the
[ __ ] best anyways he goes when he's
too old to start a band
he goes hey bill my boyfriend oh she
says sorry oh nice a female wrote in
god damn it i love when this happens
it says my boyfriend of two years has
been involved in a in has always been
very involved in theater and music he
was in bands throughout high school and
college as a drummer about a year ago he
joined a cover band which i'm totally
supportive of uh it's a really nice
hobby and i love going to his shows now
we are getting pretty close to to moving
in together
um he talks at length about our future
that um
what we need
to do to get there etc basically we are
being grown ups and despite what you're
probably thinking he is actually the one
that brings up our future and more than
me i'm not judging you i know i'm a [ __ ]
but i'm not judging here i'm reading
this open-mindedly he goes well she goes
well up
i'm reading this opening my deleuze i
keep calling you he
she says this um well about a week ago
he says that he and the chick and the
cover band want to start their own
two-person original band and based on
certain things he has said he seems
pretty serious about trying to make
something of it i.e comments about me
going on tour with him or about becoming
a rich musician musician etc my first
reaction you're 31 you don't really like
your job much parentheses people that
hate their careers tend to want to try
something else
uh you talk to me about our future and
what we have to do to get there you want
to start dedicating your time to a
two-person band i haven't said any of
this to him because i don't want to come
off as unsupportive but i mean at what
age do you face the reality and stop
trying to live out a fifteen-year-old's
dream
granted it seemed very unlikely that
anything will come of it sorry just
being honest
but doesn't this seem
like a midlife crisis ten years too
early
i should mention he also sent me this
horrendous skull tattoo today that he
suddenly wants on his arm
uh or am i being selfish and an [ __ ]
be blunt i can take it
all right um
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in this
one
um
is 31 too late to start in a band
technically no i don't think it is
um
and
when you said you know that he's having
a midlife crisis
um i hate that expression
um
and however i actually i and at first i
didn't like that you used it until he
was talking about getting the awful
skull tattoo on his arm that gave that
loaned a lot of credit credibility
to uh
the midlife crisis
comment i would say this
i think this is a person
that
wanted to be in a band a successful band
and is now 31 and is realizing like [ __ ]
if i'm gonna do this i need to do this
now
all right um
but going on and getting the skull
tattoo is it
that really i don't know
i don't know about that part that's
making me feel like your assessment of
the situation i mean without me seeing
this guy play i can't tell you but like
um
at this point he's in a cover band and
he has a job and that is your
relationship this guy is a job he has a
steady income and he has this
cover band now all of a sudden he's
going to get a skull tattoo quit his job
and potentially go on the road and take
you with him now i'm assuming you have a
[ __ ] job so he is creating an
entirely new dynamic
so you're in the right to be like what
the [ __ ] are we doing here
um
and you're in a tough position where you
don't want to be like listen this dream
that you've had but for some reason
didn't go after it the way you should
have
you know i understand being in a cover
band to like pay the [ __ ] bills but
you know if you're not making original
music there's only so far
that you can [ __ ] go as far as my
understanding of it
um so
i i actually i don't think that you're
being an [ __ ]
the skull tattoo thing is really like a
major [ __ ] red flag to me
that uh
does he have any other tattoos if he
doesn't have any other tattoos and out
of nowhere he's like all right i'm gonna
stop being in this cover band
i'm gonna finally take this [ __ ]
thing seriously and i'm gonna go out and
get some [ __ ]
awful goddamn tattoo yeah i would be
kind of concerned about the guy and what
he was doing but as far as the whole
midlife crisis thing that gets thrown
around a lot
when somebody goes after a dream
and there's nothing wrong with being 31
years old and then to assessing your
life being like wait a minute i've been
on this road i don't want to go on
i need to go on this other road
and i think a lot of times people who
aren't going after a dream
can't relate to it i'm not saying this
is you but they can't relate to somebody
going after a dream and taking a big
risk and they attribute it to having a
midlife crisis
or they don't have a dream they're just
going to work and
that's fine
working for somebody else and and
you know doing the nine to five grind as
long as you make enough money and you
have your benefits
and you like where you live like that's
fine like that's your dream
and they can't understand
somebody going after something but um
i would definitely not call it
a mid lane i don't know i guess it is
technically a midlife crisis i mean i'm
doing all the midlife crisis is like
[ __ ] i better get on the stick or the
things that i wanted in life
i'm not going to have it's like you know
me when i'm sitting there talking about
you i'm finally going to get myself a
nice [ __ ] car if i can never get
finished with this goddamn downstairs
and
you know i'm talking about some of the
cars i'm looking at
you know
and it just comes it's like if i don't
ever do this i'm never gonna do it
i think when you're young
you can be like oh i'll do this someday
i'll do this someday someday i'm gonna
do this you can lie to yourself
and
in life you have to understand that no
if i don't do this i'm never going to do
this
does that make sense if i don't go over
to [ __ ] europe i'm never going to go
to europe unless i get my [ __ ] ass
over there i'm never going to have this
car that i always wanted unless i go
down to the dealership and [ __ ] buy
the goddamn thing
um
and i don't know when people see you
when people see you step out of what
they think that you are
which is i play in a cover band and i
have this job that i [ __ ] don't like
it's very easy to say are you having a
midlife crisis he could also be having
an awakening
okay so this is a very
delicate thing
oh man it just keeps coming back to that
awful skull tattoo
to me that just seems like first of all
that's the hackiest [ __ ] tattoo out
there
you know to get you know [ __ ] i'm in
music to like die what's gonna be a guy
with a skull [ __ ] playing drums
i mean that's just bad and i just look
at that like you're dressing up like a
rock star rather than legitimately being
one
and um i don't think you're being a dick
here i think what you're an [ __ ] i
think what you're doing is
he's going to
he's making this big decision that's
going to affect both of your lives in a
major way so
you're not being a
an [ __ ] so right now what you have to
do is literally try to like defuse a
bomb
okay you got to make sure you cut the
right wire and what i mean by that is
you're able to convey your concerns like
listen i support you and all of that and
i know you don't like your day job
but
you know
i mean there's just no way to say you're
31.
you know you are 31 years of age
um
i would say look
he's kind of making a move for himself
here so you got to make a move for
yourself what i would do is it's like
i would talk him out of the skull tattoo
just say listen this is this is how you
get rid of the skull tattoo just say
listen i will support you
okay
you get with this woman you guys start
making this [ __ ] music okay
but you're not getting the skull tattoo
all right and then go down and watch
them and if they seem like they have
something who the [ __ ] knows stranger
things have happened
i would never tell somebody not to go
after a dream i would tell them not to
get the skull [ __ ] tattoo but uh see
if they have something
and if it seems like they have something
then um i i don't know
i don't know i i i don't know that is
that is a that is then i guess you have
to assess do i want to take this [ __ ]
ride
because that is a [ __ ] of a ride
um
yeah that's that's what that's
i guess
i kind of was all over the map there but
i think i came to a point no skull
tattoo
you can start making this [ __ ]
original music together and like
i mean i don't know how do you go out on
the [ __ ] road unless you're actually
doing well
what are they gonna do
you know they have to make some great
music
um
i would just lay it on the line it's
like you're asking me you're making a
major change here where music was your
hobby and now you're gonna make it your
full-time thing and you're talking about
taking me out on the road how are we
gonna afford to do this and all of that
type of stuff
um i will support you making them the
original music but you are by no means
getting a skull tattoo on your [ __ ]
arm because that is a that is the trans
[ __ ] stamp for a guy
okay unless you're in a motorcycle gang
and you murdered somebody like there
should not be any skulls on your body
all right there i said it okay and
that's it that's the monday morning
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
football
is around the corner cannot wait for
college football and all of that type of
[ __ ]
um
that's it i got nothing else to say
don't take any [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves
and please don't get a tattoo of a skull
on your body alright see you
you